I'm just curious,
what would life look like if it had
evolved from viruses instead of
bacteria?
Maybe life did evolve from viruses and
we just don't know it.
Doo,
Doo Doo,
Doo Doo.
However,
it sure looks like a bacteria went off
on their own.
And you know,
when I talking some more about me in my
book undeniable,
which I like to think of as a primmer,
a primer on evolution,
I speculated that viruses should have
their own domain of life.
The VIRA,
which in Latin would be second
declension now and uh,
in Latin,
apparently they did not have a plural of
virus.
They never needed one.
They never used it in the way we use it
today.
So I,
I don't know if life evolved from
viruses,
but in my own experience,
I am thoroughly charmed by the science
fiction story and drama to strain where
the compartmentalization of the chem
chemicals needed for life was done with
crystals rather than with membranes.
And it's science fiction,
everybody,
but bacteria are different from viruses
in that bacteria have these separate
structures,
whereas viruses seem to be a single
molecule.
What'd you might think of as a single
And so viruses are more akin to proteins
then they are at a bacteria,
but proteins are created by bacteria.
So it is very reasonable that there was
some ancestor to viruses and bacteria so
that they have in common a common
chemical ancestor proving that seems to
me it should,
it should be possible.
When I was growing up,
people celebrated and questioned and
thought hard about the Miller array
experiment or Array Miller experiment
done by these two scientists who tried
to create the conditions of the
primordial earth in a big glass flask.
And uh,
apparently the one thing they didn't all
the way figured out was sulfur,
which now people generally believe would
have come into the earth's atmosphere
from volcanoes.
When I was in school at Cornell
University,
I walked into the space sciences
building when Carl Sagan was very active
and uh,
teaching classes and stuff and they had
the early Miller experiment running.
It was the big glass flask with these
electrodes sparking because it was
presumed or it is presumed that in the
ancient atmosphere there was lightening
and this electricity could cause
chemical changes that would happen very,
very.
And so the idea is that you would look
for or try to create molecules
that through their natural existence
created copies of themselves.
And so that was the goal.
It turns out that creating amino acids,
these are biological molecules that have
a carbon with a double bond and an
oxygen on the side that turns out amino
acids aren't apparently that hard to
create.
And we find them in asteroids and we
find them all over the earth and
scientists or chemists have been able to
create amino acids that have the same
pattern but don't exist in nature or we
haven't found them.
And living systems instead,
they're very similar,
but they're not that.
We don't find them in nature.
So all this makes me think that it is
reasonable that someone could create
something akin to these primordial
atmosphere,
primordial condition.
It's on earth experiments that would
make molecules that replicated
themselves.
And we would find that the,
maybe there is a common ancestor to both
viruses and bacteria.
Whoa.
Would that molecule be dangerous?
Would it be like a super virus or the
super bacteria?
Uh,
intuitively I don't think so cause we're
all here.
Uh,
we all,
whatever happened,
happened and we,
it didn't kill us.
So,
uh,
maybe you'll be the guy that figures out
the early,
early Miller and the next step,
the next step of early Miller,
the next step of self replicating
molecules with primordial components.
It is a very compelling idea.
Keep us posted.